I have never considered myself clearly
in any field and that I think is both a
problem and an advantage it's also that
the bad story about you know maybe
you're just a dilettante as a result and
so you know I've done my best to do do
good work in each of these areas and
look deeply into it but but always in
that and the problem is the interesting
questions are always between fields and
you can never do enough you can never
get it all and I think that's one of the
real challenges we we we experience and
having a group of diverse people talk
about things actually helps you figure
this out I mean I'd never heard of this
this guy you just mentioned and yet I've
taught most of my career levels of
selection stories spent you know as
having studied with Lew Anton with Gould
with with Wilson and even you know even
Hamilton for a year I had all this stuff
in my head it's all going on and we've
been arguing about it all along and yet
to find out that there's somebody that
somebody at least thinks is terrific
that I didn't know about it's a real
surprise to me
so I think that's one of the real
advantages of this I should say that as
I mentioned before I I sort of have
wandered back and forth between these
fields never being in any one real field
and I've mostly just followed questions
all of my career and the questions lead
you elsewhere they'll eat you out of
your field oftentimes and yeah it's easy
to get in trouble when you do that and
yet I think it's the most exciting and
the most for me I feel like it's almost
a noble quest to sort of put yourself
out there and get kicked around a little
bit because you'll learn in the end you
figure out where you're wrong and you
can make new turns I think that's great
I also mentioned that you know one of
the people that really influenced me
very very indirectly was a physicist
that you know I thought I started in
physics I didn't want to go there but
earlier when Schrodinger's book what his
life I think really changed the field of
biology across a discipline even though
he was not talking about things that
were really in that discipline and I
think you know those of us in
evolutionary biology actually haven't
learned some of the lessons that he
talked about there he or at least the
hints he provided
and one of these I was hoping yeah this
this this conference interestingly
enough was especially a debate with Dan
and with with with Richard about
evolution because I've come to change my
thinking about evolution and of course
with with Jerry because of the
Schrodinger argument about the the the
problem of entropy production and it's
really changed my thinking about biology
and it's changed my thinking about the
way evolutionary biology works I think
one of the interesting things about
evolution Dan made the point that the
Darwin has contributed a lot in way many
ways to to the philosophy philosophical
world but in many ways this is a really
serious question about what kind of
causality is it how do we think about
that nature of causality and how do we
link it with other kinds of physical
causality and I think it's very close to
one of the reasons that I've sort of
shifted recent discussions towards very
very simple questions about the origins
of life is because I think we we still
don't have a clue what we're talking
about and interestingly enough I think
it's relevant to questions about mind
and how the brain works and the fact is
that I don't think we're going to get at
those questions until we become this
we're willing to follow the
interdisciplinary route work between not
just the scientists but between the
science and philosophy as well and even
though there's a lot of disconnect and I
still feel there's a lot of disconnect
and we certainly found it here I'm gonna
just make a little side comment about
the criminal justice system which I love
your comments about this my wife worked
for ten years running a what's called
the prison for special offenders these
are people were mentally ill and were
deemed so dangerous they couldn't be put
in the hospital really really extreme
personalities just trying to get into
their minds trying to figure out what
goes on is such a mind opening
experience you know it's it's it's it's
almost psychedelic you might say that
you know they're so different their
minds are so different really I think
this is also part of the neurosciences
that we don't we don't really have a
sense of how big that difference is and
there's this whole thing called
personality disorders we don't really
have good neuroscience for it we're sort
of
getting at it but it's because we don't
really have a very good general theory
about how brains work and one of one of
my problems is that every time I begin
to study one of these questions I say
okay and this is what David does to us
know what can I do physically to answer
the question so I interested early on
about human beings and language I
realized that doing the language stuff
was gonna be really hard but maybe I
could look at brains what's different
about a human brain and chimpanzee
brains and a monkey brain maybe that
would tell me something about it leads
me to other questions that my time
already oh ouch okay well let me just we
just end with one piece and that is that
this has been great I can't say that my
mind has been changed but I'm worried
about how general naturalism is and my
view of the problem is that naturalism
was implicitly a negative statement what
we're not these other guys and we
quickly said when I can talk about those
other guys but that makes naturalism
almost negatively defined and I was
worried about that as a starting point
and this is why I think mas when Massimo
says maybe we should be talking more
specific things or conferences that sort
of focus in on specific things might
have actually been a little more helpful
but it's a good start
you